hello and welcome to this video playing
DS so well maybe thinking something like
that okay so i'm not going to go for
bogo again let's play the Queens gambit
gym um yeah maybe i can i can do
something real classical him might be
seven see what is coming up with this
move yeah i recently saw an idea then
that i can try even though I have to
admit that I don't know it well they
have tried to play something with b6 in
this kind of position leading to attic /
type of game is playing very quickly hey
maybe this is not the right moment for
this I don't know it was just I'm just
being experimental here so probably here
and then c-54 the hanging points yeah
the nuances of those positions are
really difficult to understand when
exactly is this a good hanging porn
position when it is a bad one yeah all
kinds of little subtleties they are
decisive okay I wonder what he is coming
up with is he going to know hmm yeah I
wasn't quite sure what his ideas him
couldn't be six might run into some
Bishop F 694 anyway let's let's play
that not quite positive about Bishop be
one hmm i don't think he wants to set up
the battery okay so Queen 85 I guess the
battery with Quincy 223 that looks a bit
pointless in this position okay so
hmm yeah okay what are you doing there
mr. d sub L bishops is six and that
might be a move okay we'll see i was a
bit reluctant with rook c8 because of
Bishop f5 this can sometimes be a real
issue okay just just plays out a waiting
move i also have c4 in this position
which is maybe a bit is this a bit too
hasty yeah but it activates let's try
I've got Bishop before Bishop e3 this
based business with b3 move gives me a
couple of additional ideas ok I can try
to go to f5 for sure and still now I
have a couple of options bishop a three
for example it start with this and see
why is going here rooks III gives way
material so he has to go to see two and
then I have 94 for example is a move
just jump right in yeah it's interesting
that's an interesting position you
cannot takes you far as a 4s hanging
it's got a couple of coordination issues
on a very good day I might manage 95 to
d3
okay so he wants to play a 3 it seems
but this is still a good idea believe I
don't III should be should be quite an
annoyance and f3 is not a very happy
move to play I mean if I still might do
it but hmm ok that's an interesting
interesting choice 93 there might yeah
he might just go print you for something
like that hmm very interesting
yeah I have a move like rook to c6 this
is like super ambitious look to g6 okay
I'll go for that the main main danger is
the time anyway falling behind on the
clock position is okay you never know he
might fall into Knight f3 can always try
and swing look over there was part of my
my plan anyway so why not don't I have a
hard time to believe that this is great
fun with those viet pieces on c to be
one and A four let's see what is what is
coming up with him okay so might have
three years prevented yeah maybe here
maybe here threatening still not a three
and threatening night two is six very
very interesting position Bishop takes I
can take with the age pawn I can
actually take with a look wait let's not
be too quick them after taking with the
rook the
the night doesn't have that many good
squares this one okay hmm yeah I have 96
not sure that it is good though ok I
have to play one minute oh aight then a
maze amazingly complicated position here
with all pieces on your board
check okay so let's see what we can do
here g3 is hanging now won t might have
Luke takes 25 at the end of this stuff
isn't Bishop f5 forced here check time
morning Jackie that's taken take take
even more yeah that should be okay right
don't see any big issue how to do the
screen probably to g5 check
check and now he's got queen age seven
here but it's it's still Iran but ok it
is it is not really so dangerous right
it's just a couple of checks it's not
such a big deal check check and that's
it I hope check check white four of its
on time yeah tough tough tough position
it's an gadot's hanging pawn positions
they are I really well-suited sometimes
to play for wins because they got their
immensely complicated yeah all pieces
are on the board and many many
possibilities for both sides um yeah
this is this is c4 is a very
double-edged decision but it frees up
this bishop here and has it gives me
potential to play on the dark squares so
I think I'm I like this and latta Forza
is a big mistake it seems but I didn't
exploit it to the fullest okay this is
good but this is apparently better even
yeah the rooks are in a vet's in a bad
spot here man black wins material him
funny no I didn't consider that I should
a six again was good here the position
is since immensely and
he and complicated but I mean unclear
like it's clearly better as the engine
gives but it is just very difficult to
play yeah and here computer wants to
take I can actually take with this so I
need some what I'm those pieces are just
too bad this is why and why does it
trouble him back yeah he now had some
issues in on the G file this is not
check helping probably but it was hard
time how to defend Chiang Jia what's
what's falling apart check check yeah
okay finest is stronger smooth check
check it just has a couple of checks and
he's running running out of things okay
yeah interesting interesting thing I'm
not totally sure about them about the
opening there is recently they have been
tries with this kind of setup it looks
it looks very ancient and yeah like from
the 1920s or something something like
that is currently being tried as a means
of I'm getting to attack over type of
position but doing this with this move
order and not with Bishop e7 where
Bishop f4 is currently am the main move
so that you did don't get it out a coma
in the first place and after that bd7
Bishop f4 is a little bit of a different
story because here black has additional
ideas with taking and sometimes trying
to keep the pawn it's just different to
Bishop f4 against bishop 37 ok I hope
you like the game thanks for watching